gérard jugnot interview jugement dernier
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa future gérard jugnot
as-tu voler de l'argent dans le
porte-monnaie de ta maman quand tu étais
petit jamais jamais vaincu jamais avant
n'est pas large en emportant des
demandes ça c'est une chose gérard
jugnot
as-tu enfermer des élèves de sexe
féminin dans les cabinets de l'école
malheureusement non
annonce masculin masculin oui
gérard jugnot
têtu tripoter dans les chiottes du lycée
avec des copains on sunday times et
touil mais pas que
puisque gérard jugnot ces paradis si tu
te repent à l'époque dans les chiottes
du lycée avec tes copains y at il eu
pénétration au nom non
accession faire écouter les traces y on
ne dit pas je ne mange pas de ce banal
si je peux me faire mal à ses créations
gérard jugnot t'nb
gérard jugnot oui pendant ses vacances à
royan
têtu masturber en pensant à anet
[ __ ] mais comme bon il sait pas pas là
mais
sans doute oui amor amor
gérard
regrettes-tu d'avoir été aussi lourd
dans ce club de vacances en tunisie pour
obtenir de cette malheureuse ta première
pénétration
je me souviens pas
je me souviens pas mon père rousse et
anne et moi je me souviens
regrette d'avoir été aussi lourd pour
obtenir cette malheureuse j'ai pas été
lourd j'étais léger gérard balance parce
qu'elle est là je les
attends c'est la destinée de tous
gérard jugnot
tu as fumé temps premiers pétards aux
usa avec clavier et l'ermite
souhaites-tu la même chose pour ton fils
arthur s'était pas le premier mais c'est
quasiment le dernier parce que je j'ai
eu des hallucinations
c'était très fort c'est parce qu'elle
est là dedans j'ai vu des mecs avec des
canons sciés sortir des détails y est
j'ai hurlé dans cette atroce
je touche pas à ça moi je touche pas
trop fragile trop fragile gérard jugnot
tu n'aimes pas les hallucinations non
non tu as tort
georges in you we hate
profiter de ta notoriété pour séduire
pas assez
mais j'ai j'avais des sosies qui s'en
servaient à mars a semé
as-tu déjà profité de sa notoriété pour
demander aux femmes des choses contre
nature
c'est pas osé mais sera du
c'est un peu tard gérard jugnot je fais
une faveur
à
une migraine pour échapper au devoir
conjugal
non
gérard jugnot as tu déjà fait l'amour ou
sans réel désir de procréer
tout le temps
gérard jugnot
as tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu